la familia de francisco te paz asfixiado
en el trailer de texas con otras 50
personas recibió su cuerpo en guatemala
un mes después os decimos satisfechos
porque pudo llegar el cuerpo de
francisco acá en el territorio de
guatemala
el ataúd fue escoltado por sus allegados
en su natal santa cruz de sololá desde
donde salió persiguiendo el sueño
americano él se fue allá porque aquí en
guatemala lamentablemente la economía
está muy difícil
francisco con 22 años había tomado un
préstamo de 60 mil quetzales
aproximadamente 8 mil dólares para
viajar a eeuu en su desespero por salir
de la pobreza
en su humilde rancho del lago de atitlán
francisco dejó viuda a su esposa y
huérfanas a sus dos hijas de cinco y
tres años
40 portones de la papa
antonio de paz y más su hermano mayor
ahora tiene la misión de negociar con la
cooperativa una reducción en la deuda
que dejó francisco él se fue a trabajar
a ganar el dinero ya sacar adelante a su
familia verdad pero no es así
el regreso
nuevamente podría servir la noche fue
larga y dolorosa para toda la familia de
paz si más de 21 guatemaltecos que
murieron dentro del trailer francisco
hace parte de los 13 que hasta la fecha
han sido repatriados él es mi hermano su
hermana laura lo recuerda como un hombre
noble quería ayudar mi papá porque mi
papá está en deuda y tiene deuda en el
banco entonces le digo a mi papá no te
preocupes papá y yo te voy a ayudarle
al entierro de francisco acudió toda la
vereda de suites ancha para darle un
último adiós
la familia pidió a los asistentes una
donación voluntaria de dinero para la
manutención de sus hijas así como para
pagar la deuda que asumió en su objetivo
fallido de llegar a eeuu
[Música]